There is a lot coming in
space exploration this year,
big things, small things,
and space sailing.
You do not want to miss 2014.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, all.
Welcome to our first weekly
DNews space update of 2014.
I'm Trace.
Space exploration
takes a long while.
And during this
trip around the sun
our tiny planet is
heading out into the stars
in new and exciting ways.
My third favorite
space mission of 2014
has to be space
tourism in general.
The successes of private space
companies in the last few years
has created quite the visible
push for Virgin Galactic
to get their passengers'
butts up into the blackness.
Last September, Virgin
Galactic got off
the ground with its
final test flights.
600 people are already on
the list at $250 K a pop,
so they better get in
gear, especially now
that SpaceX and Orbital
Sciences are launching missions
to the ISS today and next week.
Come on, Branson, I want
to get up there too.
Let's fly.
Second is the Sunjammer.
On the ground, it
doesn't look like much.
But it's a satellite unlike
any we've ever launched before.
Riding a SpaceX Falcon
9 rocket, the Sunjammer
is a solar sail boat.
See, the sun is constantly
throwing photon particles
into space.
And though each individual
photon is tiny, all of them
together press with a constant
nine newtons of force.
And that's called
the solar wind.
The Sunjammer has
a sail on board,
packed into about the
size of a dishwasher.
But once deployed, its
3,000 square foot sail
will gather that solar wind.
And boom!
Space travel.
It's set to drop a
satellite or two.
But it is also going to
prove solar sails are
a viable method of
constant propulsion,
without on board rocket fuel.
Imagine ancient humans sailing
the seas, but in space.
That's genius.
The biggest thing I'm
excited for this year
is the test launch of
NASA's Orion spacecraft,
the next generation of
human-carrying, reusable space
launch vehicles.
The plan is for
Orion to take humans
to asteroids, the moon, Mars,
and other deep space missions.
It's been described
as Apollo on steroids.
That's not strictly
speaking true.
They took the Saturn
V from Apollo,
and then they made
it 30% bigger,
and then rebuilt
everything else.
The thing is going to
pack a whole wallop.
And they're going to launch
the full system, unmanned,
for a complete test
later this year.
Orion is set to have the fastest
reentry we have ever done.
And it's going to go
further out into space
than any human spaceflight
vehicle since 1972.
This is going to
be big all over.
What are you excited about
for this year in space?
I'm sure you can tell us.
Just go down in the comments.
Thanks, a lot for
watching, everybody.
And we'll see you next Friday
for a weekly space update.
[MUSIC PLAYING]